this video is kindly sponsored by the
morning brew
the free daily newsletter hey 42 here
nature is a dangerous place that's why i
haven't left this room for the last
eight years
wild animals extreme weather poisonous
plants
bacteria those people from the movie
deliverance
there's basically an endless list of
things out there queuing up to
kill maim or eat you
so when i heard this story about a bunch
of hikers who died in the russian
wilderness during a winter storm
i just shook my head gently and
continued sipping my cup of
self-righteous tea russia
wilderness winter
what could go wrong right but this was
no
ordinary case of a camping trip gone
awry
the death love pass incident as this
misadventure has come to be known is one
of the most enduring mysteries of our
times
and we still don't know for sure what
happened
60 years ago on the slopes of death
mountain
even though some scientists believe they
have the answer
if you get lost in the russian
wilderness then you'll want to have
morning brew before morning brew i used
to spend my morning scrolling through
various social media
aimlessly looking for something to
stimulate my sleepy neurons
but often found myself looking at the
same monotonous
news as the day before now with morning
room i can be up to date with all the
latest business tech
and finance news in just five minutes
morning brew is the perfect way to start
your day
there's no dense and tedious articles
just
relevant informative updates written in
a refreshing and witty narrative
the newsletter is delivered daily from
monday through to sunday
meaning i'm reading new content day to
day
i've learned some great stuff since
using the morning brew such as did you
know during the pandemic
luxury brands such as rolls royce have
actually seen a sales
boom and that 26 of all apple podcasts
have only ever produced one episode
which means that if you commit to
something you have an instant advantage
because roughly a quarter of your
competition doesn't
so if you're interested in business tech
or finance
like i am there's really no reason not
to subscribe to the morning brew
it's completely free and takes less than
15 seconds
and to make it even easier you can just
go ahead and click the link in the
description
to subscribe today it was january 1959
and a group of 10 hikers mostly students
at the oral polytechnic institute in
western russia
set off on their idea of a winter break
a hike over the oral mountains
a 2500 kilometer range that separates
asia from europe
the expedition was led by 23 year old
igor diatlov
an experienced mountaineer who knew how
to handle himself in the
frozen insanity that russians like to
call winter
he and every other person in the group
was a grade two hiker with ski tour
experience
and when they returned from their trip
they were to be awarded
their grade free certification the
highest available in russia
at the time so not exactly a bunch of
amateurs out for
a weekend stroll their expedition was
planned to last about three weeks
reaching a torton mountain a peak not
too far south of the arctic circle
but none of them would make it back
alive
well apart from one because he had a
funny leg
but we'll get to that in a minute the
group traveled as far north as was
possible by train
reaching the town of ivdel in the
northern soviet province
oxford lost oblast on the 25th of
january
1959. from there they caught a bus to a
place called vizhai
followed by a lorry to a logging base
called the 41st
settlement beyond that lay an
inhospitable winter wasteland
populated only by wild animals white
walkers
and indigenous tribes people known as
the mansi
after a night's rest the intrepid
explorers set off
hiking and skiing as they followed the
auspia river
into the mountains one of the group
members
an economic student named yuri udin had
to turn back due to joint pain
induced by his rheumatism but the others
continued along the trail
never to be heard from again igor
the team leader had promised to send a
telegram when they arrived safely back
in civilization
probably around the 12th of february
when no message arrived
people didn't make much of it it wasn't
uncommon for these types of trips to
take
a little longer than expected but
a week later there was still no news
and the hikers families called for a
search
a volunteer group of fellow students
went to the region to look for the
missing hikers
followed by the police and later the
military
on the 26th of february members of the
search party discovered the hikers tent
on the slopes of kolatsayakul named by
the local mansi people
it delightfully translates as death
mountain
the tent was covered in snow and
appeared to have been cut open from the
inside
out nine sets of footprints led down the
mountain to a forest
about one and a half kilometers away
some prints showed people wearing shoes
others socks and the remainder
were wearing no shoes at all suggesting
they needed to escape the tent in a
hurry
the same uneasy thoughts swept over the
entire search party
and no it wasn't did someone just let
off a killer fart inside the tent
that question was why
at the edge of the forest the searchers
found
two bodies lying next to the remains of
a small fire
yuri dorichenko and yuri krivanashenko
both men were shoeless dressed only in
their underwear
their hands and feet were badly burnt
and quivanashenko had bitten off a piece
of his own knuckle
then in a landscape thick with snow and
temperatures of minus 35 degrees celsius
it would take another three months to
locate the remaining bodies
three of them were discovered between
the edge of the forest and the tent
igor diatlov the group leader zineda
kolmogorova
one of the only two women in the party
and rustom
sloboden kalmar gorova had a long red
bruise along the right side of her body
as if she'd been hit by a cylindrical
object
slobodyn had a small fracture in his
skull
from the position of their bodies it
seemed all
three may have been trying to climb back
up the hill
towards their tent only in may
two months later did the snow fall
sufficiently
revealing the other four bodies
ludmila dubanina alexander
zolotariov nikolai tibo
brigno and alexander kolovatov
they were discovered in a ravine on the
other side of the woods
a legal inquest opened immediately after
the first five bodies had been found
determined the hikers had all died from
hypothermia
but that changed when the last four
bodies were examined
two of them had major chest fractures
whilst one had major skull damage
they were also found wearing an odd mix
of cloves
ludmila dobbinina's foot was wrapped in
a piece of the trousers belonging to
yori
kravonoshenko one of the men found next
to the campfire
whilst semyon zolotaryov was found
wearing dubba nina's hat and coat dubba
nina
was missing her tongue eyes and part of
her lips
while zola tayoff was missing his
eyeballs
kolavatov had a wound behind his ear and
an oddly twisted neck
he also had no eyebrows the big question
was what had happened
usually missing eyebrows would be easy
to explain
put any bunch of students in a tent with
vodka and it's only a matter of time
before someone loses a drinking game
and forfeits his eyebrows to a razor but
the only booze the group had was a small
flask of medicinal alcohol
besides even if they did have vodka it
wouldn't explain the other details of
this mystery
in the six decades since the incident
there have been more than
75 theories about the circumstances
that led to the deaths of these nine
hikers some people blame the yeti
which is simply an abominable idea
besides the only footprints discovered
on the mountain belong to the hikers
and none of them had a particularly big
foot
another popular suggestion is that this
was all the doing of aliens
partly because there were reports of
golden lights in the sky that night
and partly because aliens get blamed for
just about everything humans don't have
an answer
for including the disappearance of my
nan's watering cam
at one stage the leading suspects in the
investigation were members of the mansi
tribe
known to be peaceful reindeer herders
who generally kept to themselves
it was thought that perhaps the hikers
had crossed onto land
sacred to the mansi and paid the
ultimate price
but this didn't make sense because
others had crossed that land before
without trouble
and as you know by now the only
footprints found belonged to the hikers
also the coroner confirmed that the
injuries sustained by the four hikers in
the ravine
were too severe to have been caused by
humans
so it couldn't have been the mansi as a
result the investigators cleared the
mansi
of culpability but not all suspicions
faded over the years
a book was published in 2015 that
reintroduced
the sacred land hypothesis saying
the mansi hunters may have been high on
magic mushrooms
and lost their mind when the trekking
party suddenly strayed onto their land
the russian government closed the
investigation into the mata
only a few weeks after the final bodies
were found
with no clear explanation to offer the
authorities simply concluded
that the deaths were caused by a
spontaneous
power of nature before marking the files
classified
and locking them away they may just as
well have said
this was the work of naughty unicorns
and if you don't like that answer
please call the kgb these actions have
been cited
as examples of generally suspicious
behavior by the russian authorities
that's a new one and conspiracy theories
about a potential cover-up
are abound the local prosecutor lev
ivanov was the first person to
investigate the case
and led the official inquest in 1959
after initially being extremely focused
on the investigation
ivanov suddenly withdrew his interest
and closed the case
apparently under pressure from his
superiors
then he didn't speak about the event for
30 years
until 1990 when he admitted he'd been
silenced by the authorities
forced to suppress reports of fiery
objects in the sky
and strange autopsy results from the
victims of the disaster
when those autopsies were done in the
nearest town
the medical facility was surrounded by
kgb
offices not police and a large
barrel of alcohol was delivered to the
premises
some think as a way for the forensics
team to help protect themselves against
radiation
radiation had been found on some of the
clothing at the scene in the mountains
and the area was scanned with a geiger
counter to check for radioactive
contamination
which is not exactly the usual way to
handle a search and rescue mission
this weirdness has spawned rumors
that the hikers were victims of secret
weapons testing
and that the government hushed
everything up
to hide their tracks the soviet military
was known to be testing parachute mines
in the area
around that time these bombs explode in
the air
which would explain the balls of fire
described by eyewitnesses
and would also explain the injuries
suffered by the students
the missing body parts on some of the
bodies could then be down to scavenging
wild animals
as for the people who were half dressed
there's an outside chance this was due
to
paradoxical undressing a strange
phenomenon that occurs when people
develop hypothermia
suddenly they feel incredibly warm and
have the need to take
their clothes off where i come from we
call that something quite different
when the soviet regime finally collapsed
in the 90s
the files belonging to the prosecutor
ivanov
and the rest of the establishment were
released
sparking a massive surge in interest
around the death loft incident
as a result of public pressure and the
need to respond
to cray-cray conspiracy theories the
russian government reopened the case in
but was only willing to investigate
three possible outcomes
an avalanche a slab avalanche or a
hurricane
criminal action was excluded as a
possibility
because you know weather never breaks
the law
though wind speeds on the night in
question would have reached hurricane
force
the probability of a hurricane causing
the incident was eventually ruled out
but there have been some pretty
innovative ideas about
how wind could have caused a disaster
catabotic winds which are winds caused
by
cold air rushing down slopes due to
gravity
can sometimes reach hurricane speeds
though this is rare a strong catabolic
wind would
theoretically have forced the climbers
out of their tent
and sent them downhill seeking shelter
another theory is that strong winds
moving around the mountain
created extremely low frequency sounds
called
infrasound which is known to cause panic
attacks in humans
the discomfort and distress might have
driven the hikers to escape
in the dark in both scenarios the rest
of the details of the scene are
explained away by hyperthermia
and the last four people falling to
their death into a ravine
in 2020 russian authorities announced
the official cause of death
to be an avalanche this conclusion
met a number of criticisms especially
since the report lacked any clear
explanation
for how the avalanche happened there
were no
conventional signs of an avalanche at
the scene and an assessment of the
terrain
using more advanced technology showed an
avalanche to be
extremely unlikely the group had cut
their camping site into a slope that
didn't seem steep enough to cause an
avalanche
and there was no snow on the night of
the event
so there couldn't have been more snow
weight to trigger a collapse of the
slope
the footprints leading away from the
tent indicated nine people
walking down the hill not running in
panic
and hikers with their level of
experience
would have been very unlikely to camp
anywhere near the potential path of an
avalanche
the climber's injuries also didn't match
up with typical avalanche injuries
most strangely for an avalanche though
there was a nine
hour gap between the group cutting into
the snow to set up camp
and the point at which they escaped the
tent
usually in avalanche would start soon
after the snow bank had been disturbed
recently though two scientists in
switzerland
alexander pushrin and johann gum
seem to have solved the puzzle of what
happens that dark night
in 1959 they used computer software
originally developed for the disney
movie frozen
to simulate various possibilities
concluding that it was a rare type of
avalanche
that had forced the hikers to let it go
let it go they learned that the slope
was not
actually so shallow after all and that
it was
totally possible for a slab of heavy
snow to slide down the mountain
and land on the tent the snow slab
itself wouldn't have needed to be
particularly large
but the weight of the snow could have
done serious damage
in the 70s general motors ran a range of
tests on a hundred cadavers
to see what happened to the bodies in
simulated car crashes
the results were used to design car
safety belts
but puzzle puzrin angum used the data to
understand what would happen
when the force from a massive weight
landed on a human body
they discovered that when a person is
pushed against a rigid structure
the force could create internal injuries
similar to those suffered by the hikers
that night
the hikers would have been sleeping on
their skis
so when the snow slabs landed on top of
them it would have crushed them
causing chest fractures and skull
fractures
that would have badly wounded the
climbers but not immediately killed them
the avalanche would have forced them out
of the tent and down the slope
where they would have hoped to be safer
from further avalanches
this new study seems to offer a
plausible explanation
for what first went wrong that night in
february 1959
but it can't explain the bizarre events
that unfolded
afterwards it doesn't provide an answer
for
lights in the sky or radiation on
people's clothes
or missing eyebrows but
these questions will probably forever
remain
shrouded in mystery thanks for watching